ce serait quand même vachement bien
qu'on se détend d'un petit peu tout et
tout c'est avec les odeurs corporelles
on est rentré dans un cercle vicieux
plus on cache notre odeur plus on en a
honte alors que bon un corps en bonne
santé et bah ça dégage les odeurs voilà
c'est pas la mort faut se calmer avec ça
si on se lave comme il faut quand il
faut et ben tout ça c'est très gérable
ça s'assume très facilement là on a dit
qu'on était dans le cas où ça sentait
quand même un peu la bouillabaisse déjà
premier truc si il y a un problème et
que ça sent pas bon vous allez pouvoir
passer autant de coups de lingettes
banane fruit de la passion que vous
voulez ça va sentir la salade de fruits
au gambas ça a pas donné envie à grand
monde le cocktail de crevettes première
chose à faire c'est de regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passe au niveau de votre
microbiote par exemple et puis s'il y a
une infection ou un problème bah de
soigner ça mais même s'il y a pas
vraiment un problème que c'est juste que
la douche commence à remonter il y a
quelques heures et que voilà et ben les
lingettes c'est vraiment vraiment pas
l'idéal quand même non plus bah ouais le
problème c'est leur composition
là-dedans il y a plein de produits qui
peuvent être soit irritants soit causer
des allergies et qui peuvent même
déséquilibrer le microbiote donc
favoriser les infections et